When asked, “What do you want to be when
you grow up,” most children reply with the
standard, “firefighter, police officer,
teacher”.
Some go less traditional with “circus performer,
singer or professional athlete”.
I have yet to hear a child answer with “professional
farter”; yet believe it or not, this is
actually the way a select few in the world
have or currently do make their living.
Professional farters are also referred to
as flatulists or fartists, putting the “art”
in “fart”.
Paul Oldfield, better known as “Mr. Methane”,
claims to currently be the only performing
professional farter in the world.
But this article isn’t about Paul, it’s
about the man who inspired him, the amazing
Joseph Pujol.
Young Joseph Pujol, who went on to become
a world famous farter known as “Le Pétomane”
(his stage name comes from the French verb
“péter” combined with the suffix “mane”
meaning “maniac” which literally means
“fartomaniac”), discovered his unusual
talent quite by accident.
What was supposed to be a typical swim in
the sea for the young Joseph, turned out to
be a life-changing experience.
While preparing to dive under the water, Joseph
drew air into his lungs by taking a deep breath
– but air wasn’t the only thing he drew
into his body.
As he inhaled, he felt icy, cold sea water
flowing up his rear end.
In response to this most unusual occurrence,
young Joseph walked onto shore, only to discover
large amounts of sea water exiting his behind.
Knowing this was not normal, Joseph consulted
with a doctor who assured him there was nothing
medically wrong with him.
Fascinated by an ability that no other boys
his age had, Joseph decided to explore his
unusual talent and discovered that by contracting
his abdominal muscles he could suck large
volumes of water up his rectum and expel it
with great force.
No enema required!
Impressed by this humorous ability, Joseph
continued to experiment and discovered that
water wasn’t the only thing he could draw
up into his backside.
Joseph discovered that he could “inhale”
and “exhale” air through his rectum as
well.
In 1892, Dr. Marcel Baudouin actually measured
how much Pujol could “inhale” anally-
as much as two quarts of air!
The best part about this discovery was the
noise he could make while expelling the air.
Not only could he make a noise, he could vary
the noises by controlling the speed and force
of the expulsion of air, producing musical
notes.
He taught himself musical tunes and soon mastered
them.
It is a common misconception that Joseph passed
intestinal gas during his performances.
His farts were merely rectal air passed in
and out in a very controlled manner.
It was in the army that the already aptly
named Joseph Pujol was given his nickname
“Le Pétomane”.
He entertained his fellow soldiers first with
his water trick and then with the songs he
played through his “magical flute”.
Joseph had always enjoyed performing but for
now he saved his fartist act for close friends
and family.
In public, he performed only on his trombone.
After his service in the army, Joseph, an
apprenticed baker, returned to Marseilles,
which is where he was born on June 1, 1857,
to attempt a living as a baker in his own
bakeshop.
He was said to make the some of the finest
bran muffins in the South of France.
In fact, the street on which he sold these
muffins now bears his name, “rue Pujol”.
It was in his bakeshop that he began to test
the public’s reception of his other talent.
He would sometimes imitate musical instruments
using his rectal air and tell customers that
he was playing them behind the counter.
It was only at the encouragement of friends
that Joseph took his unusual musical act to
the stage.
He first performed at the Boulevard Chavre
in 1887 at the age of 30, and continued performing
all over France with immediate success everywhere
he went.
When he went to Paris in 1892, he insisted
on seeing M Vidler, the director of Moulin
Rouge and convinced him to let him perform.
He was a success there from day 1.
According to John Barber, who wrote a piece
for The Stage in May of 1997,
He took the stage in a costume of red coat,
a red silk collar and black satin breeches.
He began by explaining each impersonation
that was to follow.
This is a little girl… this is a bride on
her wedding night (small noise) … the morning
after (loud rasping noise) … a dressmaker
tearing calico (ten seconds of ripping cloth)
… and this a cannon (loud thunder).
The audience were at first astounded.
Then there would be an uncontrollable laugh,
followed by more until the whole audience
was wriggling in their seats, convulsed.
Women, bound rigid in corsets, were escorted
from the hall by nurses, cleverly placed by
the manager so that they could he seen in
their bright white uniforms.
After signing with Moulin Rouge, Joseph moved
his wife and children to Paris.
Their first child was born in 1885 and then
they had a child every two years for the next
eighteen years.
Riding the success and interest in his talents,
Joseph embarked on a very successful tour
throughout Europe and North Africa.
In 1894, the managers of the Moulin Rouge
fined Joseph 3,000 francs for an impromptu
performance he gave to help a friend who was
struggling financially.
This caused Joseph to part ways with the company.
He opened his own company called Theatre Pompadour
which included mime, magic and other variety
acts performed by his family and performer
friends.
He continued to be the star attraction there
until World War I broke out.
Four if his sons went off to fight in the
war.
One was taken prisoner and two became invalids.
This shattered the lovable family man so much
he had no desire to perform anymore.
So he and his family moved back to Marseilles
where he and his sons and unmarried daughters
ran bakeries.
In 1922, the family moved to Toulon.
There, Joseph set up a biscuit factory for
his children to manage.
This is where his wife died in 1930 and he
died in 1945.
After his death, a medical school offered
the family 25,000 francs to be able to study
his body, but not one of his children would
let them.
His eldest son Louis is quoted as saying,
“there are some things in this life which
simply must be treated with reverence.”
Apparently Pujol’s sphincter is one of them.